bonjour à tous et merci de nous
retrouver sur public sénat le 30 octobre
la commission des lois a auditionné le
vice-président du conseil d'état
jean-marc sauvé sur le projet de loi de
finances pour 2013 le budget de la
justice
c'est l'un des quatre ministères
prioritaires du gouvernement
et c'est particulièrement vrai de celui
de la justice administrative
avec 630 millions de crédits en 2013
elle devrait en principe bénéficier de
la création de 40 emplois par an
jusqu'en 2015
pour le gouvernement il s'agit de
poursuivre l'effort de réduction des
délais de jugement devant des cours
administratives d'appel et les tribunaux
administratifs
un effort qui exige énormément de temps
pour preuve
l'objectif de ramener à un an ses délais
de jugement devant la juridiction
administrative n'a été atteint pour la
toute première fois qu'en 2011
pour le vice-président du conseil d'état
jean-marc sauvé ces avancées demeurent
extrêmement fragile en raison notamment
de la montée en puissance attendue de
certains contentieux des contentieux
liés au droit des étrangers au rsa aux
questions prioritaires de
constitutionnalité ou encore au dalo le
droit opposable au logement
alors comment enrayer le phénomène
d'engorgement qui touche encore
aujourd'hui la justice administrative
des éléments de réponse tout de suite
avec l'audition du vice-président du
conseil d'état jean-marc sauvé bien
monsieur le vice président du conseil
d'état
eux nous sommes très heureux de vous
accueillir
vous remercions de nous faire l'honneur
d'avoir répondu d'avoir bien voulu
répondre à notre invitation
cette audition se déroule dans la
période de préparation de l'examen du
budget par le sénat et tout
particulièrement du rapport pour avis de
la commission des lois sur les crédits
du programme conseil d'état et autres
juridictions administratives dont le
rapporteur est notre collègue yves
détraigne qui sera donc le premier à
prendre la parole après l'exposé
liminaire de monsieur le vice président
je voulais vous dire monsieur le
vice-président que peut être cette
audition se ratait l'occasion d'élargir
le débat d'ailleurs par nature yves
détraigne élargi toujours le débat et
nous sommes intéressés par l'évolution
de la justice administrative dans notre
pays
en effet nous avons eu l'occasion de
travailler avec les tribunaux
administratives les cours
administratives d'appel et nous avons pu
constater que ceux ci j'ai encore été
une séance solennelle d'ordre au
tribunal administratif d'orléans et on
m'a dit comme on me dit toujours même si
je ne suis pas toujours responsables de
la chose qu'il ya une inflation
législative et qu'il y a des phénomène
d'engorgement enfin de lié en
particulier aux problèmes de
l'immigration intégration nationalité
et puis au droit au logement opposable
au rsa et cetera
donc je voulais vous proposer si vous
pouviez nous dire que si vous le
souhaitiez de nous dire quelques mots
là-dessus
sur la manière dont vous envisagez dont
vous voyez l'évolution de la justice
administrative eut égard eux au
quotidien des juridictions
administratives dans notre pays
de la même manière nous avons eu au
débat au sénat et nous aurons à nouveau
un débat sur les normes du en
particulier à la proposition de loi de
notre collègue eric doligé et aux
conclusions des états généraux de la
démocratie locale qui ont vu beaucoup
d'élus s'exprimer sur ce sujet et
peut-être y at-il aujourd'hui le
sentiment qu alors qu' il y à 50 ans
lorsque la direction départementale de
l'équipement d'un département décidé de
faire une route une autoroute une voie
de circulation parfois au milieu du
patrimoine historique ou pas loin de
celui ci il n'y avait pas d'opposition
tout le monde trouvait naturel que l'on
équipe ce pays et que l'on fasse des
adaptations à la circulation automobile
qui était peut-être dommageable pour
notre environnement
et voilà qu'aujourd'hui on est dans une
situation presque inverse c'est à dire
que nous connaissons beaucoup d'élus où
beaucoup de responsables publics qui
plaçait devant la situation de devoir
faire quelque chose mener à bien un
projet pour l'intérêt général de notre
de tels collectivités doivent faire face
à des collections de recours qui sont
certes tout à fait légitime et loin de
nous l'idée de dire que les et que des
citoyens ou des associations de neuneu
n'aurait pas droit à faire valoir leurs
leur intérêt ou leurs positions mais on
se demande quelquefois si on n'est pas
passés d'un extrême à l'autre c'est une
position où finalement il y avait il ya
50 ans très peu d'opposition au au
projet à une situation dans laquelle il
devient assez difficile de les mettre en
oeuvre et c'est une constatation de bon
sens que tout le monde fait et comment
simplifier les choses les alléger éviter
peut-être des délais parfois très très
dispendieux aussi très coûteux tout en
respectant bien entendu le droit et le
droit de chacune et chacun faire valoir
ses intérêts ou ses droits justement
excusez moi d'être redondant devant la
juridiction administrative
je ne veux pas abuser de cette
introduction monsieur le président mais
puisque j'ai l'honneur d'être rapporteur
pour avis en ce qui concerne le droit
d'asile
je vais tout de suite vous dire quelques
mots là-dessus ce qui m'évitera de
reprendre la parole après monsieur
détraigne de façon à ne pas vous lasser
mes chers collègues alors je voulais
vous dire monsieur le premier lieu le
vice président que je tiens d'abord à
rendre un hommage tout particulier si
vous me le permettez peut à ce que vous
avez fait en votre qualité par rapport à
la cour nationale du droit d'asile
en effet nous avons reçu madame la
présidente
et hier même il y a eu une manifestation
importante au sénat au cours de laquelle
vous vous êtes s'exprimer monsieur le
vice président vous avez bien voulu
donner des moyens à cette cour
autonome été rapporteur supplémentaires
font recruter et les délais de jugement
ont été réduits dans de fortes
proportions et je tiens à le souligner
parce que l'on dit souvent que les
délais sont trop longs
il y a eu une action très remarquable à
cet égard et puis je me permettrais de
dire que la décision du gouvernement
vous savez qu'ici nous avons une grande
indépendance d'esprit et cette
indépendance d'esprit me permet de dire
que le fait que le montant de l'aide
juridictionnelle devant cette cour
nationale du droit d'asile soit passé de
187 euros par dossier à 374 euros est
une décision positive
ça pourrait d'ailleurs donner des idées
dans d'autres domaines
je voulais vous demander plus
précisément vous posez plus précisément
trois questions la première sur les
rapports entre la semaine des as et
l'ofpra il y a un fort taux de recours
85% par rapport aux décisions prises par
l'ofpra donc devant la cndr or la cnda
aujourd'hui accordent davantage de
statut de réfugié ou de protection
subsidiaire que l'ofpra
n'y at il pas là quelque chose de
paradoxal
est ce qu'il ne serait pas plus logique
que l'ofpra apporte un avantage de ceux
de réponse positive aux demandes ce qui
d'une certaine façon désengorgerait la
la cnda nonobstant le fait que la cndr
dispose grâce à vous notamment de
davantage de personnels et de moyens
deuxièmement je voulais vous demander
monsieur le vice-président au regard des
décisions de la cour européenne des
droits de l'homme
ce que vous pensez de la procédure dite
prioritaire
est-ce que celle-ci vous paraît fondée
en droit et quelles conséquences pensez
vous en tant que vice-président du
conseil d'état qu'il soit utile ou
nécessaire
de tirer des récentes décisions de la
cour européenne des droits de l'homme
enfin la troisième question sera
relative à ce mouvement de grève des
avocats devant la cnda que nous avons
constaté récemment à votre avis quelles
sont les causes de cette grève remarquer
que nous pourrions poser la question aux
avocats eux-mêmes se serait sans doute
plus pertinent
mais comme je sais que vous avez
beaucoup insisté pour qu'il y ait une
médiation monsieur le vice président et
vous avez d'ailleurs confié à cette
médiation a été confié un membre éminent
du conseil d'état qui est jean marie
delarue que nous avons souvent celui-ci
au sénat je voulais vous demander si
vous pouvez nous en dire plus sur cette
médiation et sur les évolutions dans le
fonctionnement de la cnda auquel vous
pensez
excusez moi d'avoir été un petit peu
long un peu long je vous donne tout de
suite la parole si vous le voulez bien
monsieur le vice président pour votre
déclaration pour votre intervention
liminaire
merci merci monsieur le président je
voudrais d'abord faire un point général
sur la situation de la juridiction
administrative en faisant écho à votre
intervention liminaire
nous avons été confrontés au cours des
25 dernières années et spécialement
encore au cours des dix dernières années
à une contradiction très forte entre des
délais de jugement qui étaient
excessivement ou anormalement longs et
une demande de justice qui progressait
très fortement de l'ordre de 6% par an
ce qui est la tendance depuis plusieurs
décennies depuis plus de 40 ans et
mon les résultats qui ont été obtenues
et je vais parler de la dernière
décennie sont des résultats qui peuvent
je crois être qualifié de tout à fait
satisfaisant puisque les délais
prévisibles moyen de jugement qui
représente la capacité de la juridiction
à résorber son stock
si le flux d'affaires nouvelles
s'interrompent et est passé en première
instance de près de 20 mois à un peu
moins de 11 mois donc en dessous d'un an
dans un contexte de très forte
croissance
on appelle l'amélioration est encore
plus forte puisque on est passé d'un dd
de 3 ans et 1 mois à un peu moins d'un
an
n'étant aux oies et demi alors ces
résultats sont liés à l'augmentation des
moyens qui a pu être obtenue au long la
dernière décennie mais les deux
dernières décennies
cette amélioration est également lié à
un effort très sensible des magistrats
qui traite aujourd'hui 25% d'affaires de
plus qu'au début de la période
en première instance 25% à faire et je
peux vous dire qu'au début des années
2000 des magistrats en cause ne
travaillait et déjà de manière
extrêmement intense
la croissance du nombre d'affaires river
par magistrat était de 30% dans des
cours d'appel
donc là juridique administrative ne
s'est pas uniquement reposer sur
l'apport des tribus sion de moyens
supplémentaires
alors en dépit du succès qu'on peut
observer et donc à l'aune du délai
prévisible moyenne jugement l'objectif
de réduction des délais de jugement
n'est pas encore atteint et des
indicateurs restent à améliorer
d'abord 11 tribunaux administratifs et
deux cours d'appel ont encore des délais
prévisibles moyens supérieurs à un an le
délai moyen constatée pour les affaires
ordinaires
une fois qu'on a défalqué les affaires
qui se règlent par ordonnance hier sans
audience sans débat contradictoire par
rejet une fois qu'on a des faibles
qu'aimer procédure d'urgence notamment
les reconduites à la frontière les
affaires qui se juge au terme de la loi
en 72 c'est la loi qui nous l'imposent
on n'est pas vertueux de les traitants
sont 12 heures ça contribue à faire
baisser noter d une fois qu'on a
défalqué toutes ces affaires le dd moyen
constatée pour les affaires ordinaires
en réalité il est encore de deux ans
aujourd'hui dans les tribunaux
administratifs et notre objectif doit
être de rapprocher cdd les délais moyens
constatés ddd prévisible et de garantir
un délai maximal de jugement de un an et
demi en première instance et en appel
donc nous avons encore des marges de
progression voudrais aussi dire que le
taux de couverture c'est-à-dire le ratio
entre les affaires traitées des affaires
enregistrées est encore inférieur à 100%
dans quatorze tribunaux administratifs
et 5 cour administrative d'appel
donc voilà quatorze tribunaux 1 sur 38
et
combien 5 cour d'appel sur huit qui
aujourd'hui ne traite pas autant
d'affaires qu elles en reçoivent depuis
début d'année c'est dire à quel point
des progrès sont spectaculaires mais
extrêmement fragile le nombre des
affaires qui sont en stock depuis plus
de deux ans il est encore dans les
tribunaux administratifs de 14%
vous me direz qu au début de la décennie
nous n'étions pas à 14 les taux à 40 %
donc le progrès évidemment tout à fait
spectaculaire mais nous avons des marges
alors plusieurs éléments laissent
entrevoir une reprise marquée du
contentieux
ce que je voudrais dire notamment comme
toile de fond du budget pour 2013
contentieux du droit au logement
opposable augmente très sensiblement
il atteint près de 8500 à faire en 2011
la pente a été de 56 % en 2010 une
augmentation de 13 % en 2011 et nous
pensons qu'une augmentation de 8% par an
qui est assez inéluctable va porter ce
conte ont su à 12000 affaires par an en
le contentieux du rsa qui s'élevait à
1325 affaires en 2009 a doublé pour
atteindre 2750 en 2011
il va poursuivre sa progression les cinq
premiers mois de l'année 2012 marque une
progression de 50 % correspondant aux
cinq premiers mois de 2011
donc on voit bien aussi progression même
limité à 30% par an sur la période 2013
2015 porterait ce contentieux en 9100
affaires en 2015 soit près de 5000 à
faire de plus que ce que nous
connaissons contentieux du permis de
conduire représente 11 mille à faire et
c'est un contentieux qui est assez
indexée sur le nombre de radars qui sont
disposés sur la voirie c'est le
contentieux des naturalisations connaît
depuis 2009 des naturalisations connu
une progression très marqué avec
pratiquement plus 120% depuis 2009 il
atteint 4600 à faire en 2011
cette tendance s'est confirmée en 2012
nous avons aussi un effet question
prioritaire de constitutionnalité le
conseil d'état en a traité plusieurs
centaines dans des trois mois qui a été
fixé par la loi organique de décembre
2009 que le dispositif fonctionne très
bien dans les cours d'appel
il y en a eu 416 dans les tribunes
illustratif 1035 s'ajoute au reste et ça
ne fait pas des numéros supplémentaires
puisque les questions prioritaires sont
posés dans des dossiers qui sont
enregistrés et ça ne participe pas des
statistiques que je viens de présenter
alors l'inquiétude vient surtout de
l'impact de la loi du 16 juin 2011
relative à l'immigration l'intégration
et la nationalité
cette loi a modifié la ligne de partage
entre la compétence du juge
administratif la compétence du juge
judiciaire est à la fois le juge
initiative traite plus de dossiers et
pour chaque dossier qu'ils traitent au
lieu de connaître de deux décisions il
connaît désormais de cinq décisions
administratives et on le voit bien des
audiences sont forcément plus longue les
décisions sont beaucoup plus motivés
beaucoup plus longue avait dit g et le
contentieux des étrangers à vouvoyer
progressé de 50% au premier semestre de
2011 par rapport au premier semestre de
2010 était avant l'entrée en vigueur de
cette loi et nous avons
une nouvelle progression donc en 2012
par rapport à 2011 au 30 septembre 2012
la progression s'établit à 18 % 18 %
alors même que l'arrêt de la chambre
criminelle de la cour de cassation
rendue le 5 juillet 2012
excluant la garde à vue des étrangers
pour le sun séjour irrégulier donc enfin
d'emprisonnement et est de nature à
faire mécaniquement baisser le nombre de
décisions attaquable donc en réalité 18
% d'augmentation de 2012 par rapport à
2011 ne représente pas la réalité d'un
croissance du contentieux qui va
clairement dépassé 30% alors une
augmentation de 30% pour un contentieux
qui représente 1 ou 2%
ça n'est pas problématique mais pour un
contentieux qui représentaient 26 27% du
contentieux quand vous mettez 30% en
plus de 26 27
on voit bien d'efforts que cela
représente donc toutes ces perspectives
nous conduisent à penser que nous allons
en réalité restés dans la croissance du
contentieux qui est d'au moins 6% par an
dans les années qui viennent
et donc c'est la progression constatée
en longue période et c'est pour
permettre à la juridiction illustrative
de faire face à cette augmentation
prévisible du contentieux que nous avons
demandé et obtenu 40 création d'emplois
par an dans le budget triennal 2013 2015
alors mécaniquement ses créations ne
permettent pas de faire face en réalité
au volume que j'ai indiqué en réalité
elles permettent de traiter une
croissance de 3% des affaires par an pas
une croissance de 6%
donc on ne saurait exclure dans les
années qui viennent une légère
dégradation des délais de jugement nous
ferons tout pour rester bien sûr en
dessous d'un an pour les prive les
misrati fait des cours d'appel mais nous
sommes sur une ligne
crede qui est une ligne de crête
particulièrement délicate à tenir
donc je voulais que la représentation
nationale en soit informé nos progrès
sont spectaculaires spectaculaire
d'autant que la décennie 2000 2012 fait
suite à une décennie antérieure qui a
été également marquée par de très
importants progrès qui ont été à
l'époque notamment marquée par la
création la mise en place et l'extension
des compétences des cours d'appel qui
ont été installés le 1er janvier 1989 et
progressivement ont pris en charge la
totalité du contentieux de la peine donc
en dépit de ses considérables progrès
nous sommes toujours dans une situation
de grande tension pour les conditionnels
du droit d'asile monsieur le président
la situation et
délicate nous étions 2009 un délai
prévisible de jugement qui était de 15
mois les affaires sont beaucoup plus
homogène à la cour nationale du droit
d'asile on n'a pas les affaires qui se
règle comme le référé liberté en 48
heures puis d'autres affaires qui
peuvent se régler en plusieurs années
nous étions à 15 mois et 12 jours nous
avons légèrement fait reculer ce d'aidé
en 2010 en 2011 nous sommes revenus à 9
mois 9 mois 9 mois et 5 jours
notre objectif est d'arriver à six mois
en 2015
dès cette année nous aurions nous
aurions pu revenir à 7 mois comme délai
traitement des recours devant la cour
nationale doit zine en vérité comme il
ya eu un conflit avec les avocats qui a
entraîné une suspension des audiences
pendant un mois en réalité donc le
termineront l'année un dd non pas de
sept mois mais plus près de huit mois
alors vous avez posé plusieurs questions
la première effectivement vous souligner
monsieur le président à juste titre que
aujourd'hui la cour nationale du droit
d'asile donne
reconnaît le statut de réfugié dans un
plus grand nombre de dossiers clough
prat jagdhof prat statuts rejettent
environ 90% des demandes enfin en tout
cas le taux de rejet de l'offre ait aux
approches de 90% des demandes et le taux
de réformation donc de la cour nationale
du droit d'asile est relativement élevé
car l'idée de l'ordre de 2 20%
il est de 20 % et donc 20% par rapport à
des recours dont vous avez rappelé la
proportion le taux de recours et de 2
85%
eh bien ça fait que au total la cour
nationale du droit d'asile reconnaît
plus fréquemment le statut de réfugié
clough prat c'est une question
effectivement kid est souhaitable que
peut-être nous abordions avec l'ofpra
je dirais toutes choses étant égales par
ailleurs parce que il est effectivement
extrêmement important que l'ofpra
tiennent compte de la jurisprudence de
la cour nationale du droit d'asile
mais il faut bien mesurer aussi qu'il ya
en dépit du volume toujours plus de
cinquante mille demandes d'asile en
première instance il ya un
renouvellement des flux et les flux non
pas là numériquement il représente le la
même importance plus de 50000 mais ils
peuvent se renouveler
il ya des régions des régions qui
peuvent générer des demandes d'asile
plus fondées mieux fondées que des
demandes provenant d'autres régions et
donc on ne peut pas dire compte tenu de
la variation de la situation gpo
géopolitique dans beaucoup de pays
beaucoup de régions du monde
on ne peut pas dire qu'ils aient des
enseignements qu'on puisse tirer
durablement de cet écart mais mais cet
écart pose question pose question je
ferai peut-être une autre remarque
sur les relations avec l'ofpra qui est
un peu en relation aussi avec le litige
que vous avez évoquées ou en tout cas le
mouvement collectif qui a été observé
c'est que nous sommes confrontés à une
situation et ça peut expliquer aussi
d'ailleurs le taux d'émission nous
sommes confrontés à une situation dans
laquelle le juge de l'asile se prononce
sur des requêtes écrites soutenu
oralement et sans contradiction
je veux dire par là que l'offre a pour
des raisons je ne qualifie pas qu'ils
sont certainement aisément
compréhensible l'ofpra n'est pas en
mesure d'assurer ni sa défense écrite ni
non plus une défense oral à l'audience
donc ça peut aussi conduire à expliquer
les taux relativement élevés d'admission
au stade de la cour nationale du droit
d'asile
ça crée aussi un autre effet qui peut
être préoccupant qui n'est pas sans lien
avec le mouvement collectif qu'est venue
la cour nationale du droit d'asile
c'est que le requérant en l'absence de
contradicteurs il est face aux juges
et du coup
juge de l'asile ou le rapporteur par des
questions qu'il pose peut-être perçu
comme étant l'adversaire
j'essayais de trouver un synonyme mais
que je ne trouvais pas mais mais voilà
ce qui n'est pas sans lien sur la
perception de l'audience par le
justiciable et donc
iliad a un vrai sujet l'offre a bien sûr
n'émarge pas au programme 165
c'est une autre affaire mais c'est une
question qui est extrêmement importante
vous avez posé monsieur le président des
questions de la procédure prioritaire et
notamment la question donc iem contre
france du 4 février 2012 qui jugent donc
dont c'est la rédaction de la décision
de la cour européenne des droits de
l'homme dans les circonstances
particulières les circonstances
particulières d'un étrangers en
rétention administrative
n'ayant pas eu du fait de la complexité
de ces situations la faculté de préparer
utilement la défense de ses intérêts des
exigences donc du procès équitable n'ont
pas été respectées avec une procédure
qui est suspensive uniquement au stade
de l'octroi du statut de réfugié mais
pas au stade du recours juridictionnel
devant la cour nationale du droit
d'asile
donc je crois que des autorités
françaises ont dit les autorités
françaises jeu je m'exprime tout à fait
largement
les autorités françaises estiment que
cet art est tel qu'il est rédigé ne
condamne pas par principe la procédure
prioritaire
il nécessite seulement des aménagements
et donc un décret devrait être pris pour
permettre en réalité de redéfinir le
périmètre de la procédure prioritaire de
telle sorte que dans des circonstances
telles que celle de la sphère im contre
france est bien la procédure prioritaire
ne soient pas mises en oeuvre que donc à
la fois on se conforme pleinement à la
jurisprudence de la cour européenne des
droits de l'homme mais sans aller
jusqu'à abandonner toute procédure
prioritaire
voilà vous avez fait monsieur le
président que l'effet france donc grève
des avocats la cour nationale du droit
d'asile
j'ai donc désigner un médiateur en la
personne du contrôleur général des lieux
de privation de liberté jean-marie
delarue qui je crois susciter la
confiance de toutes les parties le
médiateur doit remettre ses conclusions
au tout début du mois de novembre et il
aura l'occasion de faire une restitution
de ces de ses observations de ces
conclusions de ces recommandations dans
la première décade du mois de novembre
avec l'ensemble des parties je pense que
et la célébration du 60e anniversaire de
la cour nationale du droit d'asile hier
la montre et je pense que
des investigations extrêmement
approfondie du médiateur le climat dans
lequel ces contacts se sont déroulés ont
déjà contribué à apaiser les tensions et
donc les relations au sein de de la cnt
a mais c'est évidemment un dossier tout
à fait prioritaire qui requiert toute
notre attention est rappelé qu'à
l'époque où j'étais rapporteur à la
commission de recours des réfugiés
donc c'était évidemment il ya bien plus
de 30 ans 35 ans il n'y avait pas
d'avocat dans bien plus d'une affaire
sur deux aujourd'hui parce que eh bien
les droits de la défense sont beaucoup
mieux organisés parce que l'aide
juridictionnelle est accessible aux
étrangers qui sont entrés
irrégulièrement sur le territoire
français notamment pour demander l'asile
et ceci est effectif depuis le 1er
décembre 2008
ça résulte d'une loi de 2006 il y à des
avocats dans 85% des affaires est il
bien évident que
la nature des relations qui
s'établissent entre le juge les parties
j'ai parlé aussi d'une partie qui n'est
pas présente
donc c'est toute cette relation a été
totalement transformé
je ne parle pas non plus des conditions
d'accès au dossier de l'audiencement des
affaires audiencement qui doit
s'efforcer de tenir compte mais pas
quand même dans une mesure qui
conduisent à remettre en cause la
continuité de la justice qui doit
s'efforcer de tenir compte aussi des
disponibilités des avocats c'est un
avocat peut difficilement siéger siéger
nous représentait les parties dans cinq
audiences simultanées qui se déroule au
même moment à la cour nationale du droit
d'asile
voilà les quelques éléments merci
beaucoup monsieur le vice président
alors nous allons tout de suite donné la
parole à yves détraigne rapporteur pour
avis du budget de la justice
administrative
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
président merci pour votre présentation
on a déjà eu l'occasion de rencontrer
quinzaine de jours au conseil d'état je
vous poserai donc que trois questions
quelques questions ma vengerait
effectivement témoigner de ce que il ya
des efforts de productivité réelle qui
ont été faits depuis quelques années
dans les juridictions administratives
j'ai eu l'occasion ces dernières
semaines où ces derniers mois de visiter
plusieurs juridictions administratives
et j'ai pu constater que la
dématérialisation est une réalité dans
les juridictions administratives et que
ça passait très bien
pratiquement auprès de toutes les
générations de magistrats c'est souvent
quelque chose qui est un objectif un
projet dans beaucoup de services
d'administration là on a une juridiction
qui s'est déjà approprié la
dématérialisation effectivement c'est
assez intéressant de voir les les gains
de productivité qui sont faits de même
que j'ai apprécié beaucoup de choses
certes mais j'ai agi noter
particulièrement aussi le reporting qui
est fait sur les affaires en cours les
nouvelles affaires enregistre et le lait
les contentieux divers il ya un
véritable tableau de bord commun à
l'ensemble des juridictions illustrative
et sans aucun doute qui est ton dont la
qualité l'intérêt est appréciée pour
tousser
il ya c'est vrai que les jeunes x
ministre hâtive ont fait de gros efforts
de productivité depuis quelques années
je voudrais revenir sur quel quelques
points il ya une inflation des
contentieux vous l'avez rappelé avec
quelques chiffres assez frappant au
début de votre exposé il y a eu un
certain nombre de réformes de procédure
qui ont été faites comme la dispense de
conclusions du rapporteur public dans un
certain nombre d'affaires et d'autres et
d'autres évolutions de procédure sur
lesquelles je ne vais pas revenir
quel premier bilan est ce que je peux
vous demander quel premier bilan vous
portez sur ces évolutions ou deux
deux procédures parce que j'ai lu sous
votre plume qu'au delà de ces évolutions
de procédure il fallait sans doute
réfléchir à la réduction du nombre de
contentieux or c'est pas du tout ce qui
se passe aujourd'hui donc où on est là
la réflexion aujourd'hui par rapport à
la manière de réduire éventuellement les
les contentieux est ce qu'on réfléchisse
à un recours préalable obligatoire est
ce qu'on réfléchisse à une procédure de
conciliation autre chose je pense que ça
pourrait être intéressant que nous y
quelques mots sur ces pistes de de
réflexion de deuxième point il y a eu d'
instaurer depuis peu de temps un droit
de timbre dont nous sommes tous
conscients la commission des lois qui
s'appliquent à la justice judiciaire me
s'applique aussi à la justice
administrative les fameux 35 euros
administratif
est-ce que ça a un impact sur le nombre
et l'évolution des contentieux que vous
avez à régler et le cas échéant quel
type de contentieux se trouvent
concernés par ce seul droit timbre
essayez vous pouvez nous le dira quelle
est votre appréciation avoue
vice-président du conseil d'état sur la
mise en place de de ce droit de péage
j'allais dire avant de pouvoir engager
un contentieux ou en tout cas de
mener à bien et enfin pour laisser le
temps à mes collègues de pose également
des questions
je voudrais vous interroger sur le droit
au logement opposable
c'est une des c'est une des sources
récentes de contentieux qui sont
clairement inflationniste mais je me
suis laissé dire que ce contentieux
était relativement formelles parce qu'il
suffisait pas de décider devant le
tribunal que telle famille avait le
droit à un logement pour
qu'effectivement sans problème de
logement soit réglé voilà alors ok est
ce que vous avez et pouvez vous nous
donner votre votre approche sur cette
question du contentieux
le législateur peut-il améliorer cette
situation voilà en quelques mots
cela serait dans les questions que je
souhaitais vous poser mais c'est la
place à mes collègues aussi si monsieur
détraigne je vais demander au saut trucs
aux collègues s'ils souhaitent
s'exprimer
j'ai un premier inscrit qui est monsieur
cheylard monsieur g d'are merci monsieur
le président monsieur le président
devrait intervenir sur un domaine du
contentieux un peu particulier qui les
contentieux d'urbanisme et veut nous
avait mentionné tout à l'heure les
réduction des délais et ce n'est pas le
cas dans le domaine du contentieux
d'urbanisme
lorsqu'un paix lui est attaquée devant
le tribunal administratif je connais
bien le cas et bien les délais sont
épouvantablement long minimum deux ans
avant que le tribunal administratif ne
statue quand en plus s'ajoute un recours
devant la cour administrative d'appel
on arrive à 4 ans facilement voire cinq
ans alors là il ya donc un élément qui
est paralysant pour les collectivités
locales et qui est extrêmement gênant
pour définir une politique en matière
d'urbanisme
nous interrompons cette audition en
place au direct sur les chaînes
parlementaires édition spéciale
consacrée aux annonces de jean marc
ayrault sur la compétitivité édition
spéciale que je vous présente avec
arnaud ardoin bonjour avenant dont je
lauriane ravi d'être là avec vous sur ce
plateau
de même alors depuis 9 heures le premier
ministre jean-marc ayrault réuni une
partie du gouvernement pour un séminaire
gouvernemental consacré aux suites à
donner au rapport gallois remis hier au
premier ministre
et dans quelques minutes jean marc
ayrault s'exprimera et dévoilera donc à
sa feuille de route consacré à la
compétitivité et pour commenter ces
annonces avec nous sur le plateau amical
la baisse notre éditorialiste politique
bonjour antoine brunet économiste joseph
thouvenel vous êtes vice président de la
cftc et laurent vont ski vice-président
de croissanceplus le première question
mais qu'est ce qu'on doit attendre d'un
d'une telle présentation du premier
ministre
thi minh en cédant quelques minutes des
fuites déjà dans la presse nous ont déjà
quasiment tout dévoiler qu'est ce qu'on
doit attendre de ce que vous